the gyro can experience and so it's it's
awesome and their way of life is so
incredible and so that's what we're
trying to help the kings of Uganda right
now so our trip even Brady who you know
Brady was messed up so all of us were
there just sick over there he's saying
what do you mean I messed up
culture shock oh and not just culture
shock but what is it whenever you it's
not just PTSD like you like just jolted
with with devastation of like in shock
and shock yeah in fact we we could play
that one video now it's a documentary
trailer that cash app helped fund I mean
friends of Joe Rogan and this trailer
video is just from our last trip to
Uganda
it's got sound but I'll speak over it
but it kind of sums it all up this
little boy named Paulo you'll see in his
eyes what I mean when you see this boy's
eyes you'll know just some of the
devastation that he's gone through and
seen you can see like the eyes are the
windows to our soul you can see the
heart heartbreak in this kid I think
it's called the bots wha trailer video
or something like that Jamie but it's um
it's got an opening where it's just like
thanks to cash app but then it shows how
long is this video it's about a minute
and a half
okay well we'll play this then we got to
wrap this thing okay got one more thing
to give you
so that is in the simile key National
Forest that's King Zito and the red but
they were driven from their ancestral
home and they're struggling to survive
and this is on that one acre of land
that they live on that's some mushrooms
but they live in eight structures on
this one acre of land and forced to live
in this unknown village and literally
don't have any food or clean water
that's where they live in those shelters
that's what they've been given when they
were kicked out of the forest but
there's no way that's the sewage running
through their village and just being
abused
yeah beyond imagination because they
think they're a cure for HIV that woman
was raped because these men thought they
would be cured that's a little palo
there you can see in his eyes and
thought they'd be cured by having sex
with her yep we're by collecting their
blood and Sao Paulo was held down and
that's the new land five acres of land
that we were able to get them so this is
a celebration just kind of transitioning
into dancing with the drums and the
leaves but now they have hope that
they're gonna survive and here's at the
school where they're getting new water
and they're in class for the first time
they were told that they couldn't go to
school that they wouldn't be that they
couldn't learn and now actually the top
five students at the school over the
last six years are all bathua pygmy
children that's the new well that
they're drinking from one of them so
this just celebration they're learning
some MMA and we're there to help come
alongside them and say hey how can we
with our vision to defeat hate with love
our mission to knock out bullying
worldwide how can we do this in a
practical sustainable way and so yeah Jo
like that little boy Paulo that you saw
has scars on him from people holding him
down and slicing him open collecting his
blood because they think he's the cure
for HIV or the women they're being
sexually assaulted some terrible stuff
but what we want to do to kind of sum up
this documentary when we get there is is
having newly informed them back in
school them far
for themselves I'm selling it at the
markets and then yeah and then also
stateside here
[Applause]